>>Elena: Traditionally there
were these 50-minute periods
where you did this textbook, and
this textbook, and there was lecture;
however even when that was
developing and now we know
that kids don't learn well that
way, and we know that many students
in certain socioeconomic groups
don't particularly don't learn well
that way, and if we want to
close the achievement gap
and reach those students, we
need to teach differently.
And so in some ways it does go
against what many people grew
up with, what they think
constitutes good education,
even what their administrators
are telling them they have to do.
We have a lot of research
and evidence on our side
that says this is how kids learn
best by integrating studies,
by experience-- learning through
many different modalities,
by expressing your learning
through different learning-
with different learning styles, so I
think we are being given permission
by the abundance of research
that says this works.
This does take more time, it's more
planning, it's more- it's logistics
and thinking but it's so much
more rewarding and it works.
>>To be able to plan an
interdisciplinary unit you need
to know what's expected of those
students in those other areas
so I would need to have the
standards for math, science, history,
everything, spread out
all over around me,
and I would be constantly
referring to them and looking
at kind of going back and forth.
These are my goals.
Where are there standards in other
areas that fit in and support that?
Or where- how can I modify my
goals so that I can actually pull
in that sixth grade
math standard that's
like statistics that's rarely
addressed in any depth and pull
that in and support their learning
in this class in this unit.
So I would be doing
a lot of planning.
I would be talking to other teachers
about what is it in sixth grade math
that you feel like would be helpful
for students to have reinforced
in my class, or which are standards
that are not addressed enough
that you really wish there was
some way that they could bring in?
And then I would go back to my
clients and see whether they worked.
No? Sorry, that doesn't work here.
>>I think one of the keys to success
in designing an interdisciplinary
unit is doing a lot of research
on the Internet and books
and everybody you know.
>>I'm a firm believer in
asking for what you want
from everybody even though
you may not even know them.
And just keep looking, keep asking,
and there are tons of
resources out there.
>>When you're planning for
any kind of unit again,
you need to know what do
you want them to understand?
How am I going to know if
they're understanding it?
And so when you start, before you
start you need to have rubrics
or assessment measures
already created
so you know really clearly what
you're looking for and then you need
to communicate that to students
so they know it's not a mystery.
What am I expected to do?
What is it going to look
like if I get an "A"?
And then all the way along you need
to be doing formative assessments.
Are they getting it?
If not, what do I need to
do, how do I need to reteach,
how do I need to restructure
my class,
what other strategies can I do?
Changing instruction, give
them another assessment,
but you need to know before you go
into it what are you looking for.
>> So at ASCEND I taught a
core of history and English
and my partner-teacher taught math
and science and we followed a model
of teaching of designing curriculum
and instruction called
expeditionary learning.
And one of the central
curricular components
of that was to integrate curriculum.
>>To make instruction as authentic
and meaningful as possible for kids,
to connect it to their world, to
the real world, to be responsive
to their needs and interests.
In the beginning of 2003 the
likelihood of there being a war was
on the forefront of
everybody's mind and newspapers,
and although I had sort of
mandated curriculum I was supposed
to cover standards the
students really wanted to know
about what was going on with this
war and this conflict and wanted
to understand it deeper
and fortunately there were enough
connections to be made and there were
so many language arts standards
that could be addressed in designing
that curriculum and I'm emphasizing
this sort of external pressure
of standards and curricula
that we have to teach
because that is the reality.
But what I found then and still
believe now is that you can do it.
It's just about looking creatively
and getting some administrative
permission.
You can say "Look-it, in this study
of the war they did persuasive
writing, they did debate,
they did poetry, they
wrote personal essays,
they went to other
schools and did teach-ins.
They taught their parents.
They spoke to newspapers."
And all of that you can still do and
meet standards and you can do that
and meet the interests and
needs of your students.
>>If you're a beginning teacher and
you're starting to want to tread
into interdisciplinary studies
and integrating more curriculum
and it seems overwhelming and you
can barely get the kids to sit down
and be quiet and open
their textbooks,
I would say take small steps and
it's okay and use the textbook
and make some small
goals for yourself
like once this month I
will bring in a poem.
Or I will have one
guest speaker this year.
Or I will take some small steps.
Get- it is okay to get the classroom
management set, feel comfortable,
have- start understanding
the curriculum,
understanding the standards and then
there may be a unit that you'll think
about doing, a two-week
unit in the spring.
It doesn't have to be a semester.
It can be a one-week, a two-week
unit where you're going to focus
on something and you
already have ideas about how
and you can spend six
months mulling it over,
asking whenever you have
a second once-a-month
to "Do you have any ideas?
I want to do something about frogs
and do you have any ideas
about what I can do?"
So it's a great way to start
making connections with colleagues
and asking colleagues what they
if you're a beginning teacher
and taping on their resources.
But take small steps and think
about it as a long-term goal.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org.